before we get started a quick reminder
that the bbc is a transphobic
organization platforming people who are
literally calling for the genocide of
trans women if you don't know what i'm
talking about you will find links in a
pinned comment below with my video on
the topic as well as a more recent one
from the youtuber sean and with that out
of the way on with the show
oh please don't blink
if you blink i'll be able to move and
then i'll have to actually talk about
this
[Music]
[Music]
damn it
village of the angels doctor who flux
episode four
well um
i had expressed a small amount of hope
uh for this episode actually when i
talked about the last episode um because
i noted that
uh the pattern at least for this first
bit of the uh the thing seemed to be
uh
an episode about sort of the major plot
and then a more or less self-contained
one that ties in somewhat and then an
episode about the major plot and then
this i assumed was going to be something
closer to episode 2 which
i actually liked a fair bit i had
issues i'm me i have issues with things
i love so yeah i had issues with that
but i did enjoy it for the most part
and i had hopes that maybe
i would enjoy this
i did not
i mean honestly this is going to be
rehashing a lot of the things i said in
the last review which is that i can see
a few kernels of ideas that could have
worked if they were
focused on and made more central
but
this thing is juggling
too much of the main plot and doing it
worse than war of the santarans did
so
this
this this this was rough
i held on to hope a decent way
into it and if i'm being completely
honest the
the way in which the angels are depicted
in terms of the actual
you know shots the way they move the
setups the build up the tension is
decently done
it doesn't try and reinvent the wheel
with them rather just find ways to build
the appropriate tension around the stuff
that we already know the angels do the
angels up to this point have operated
primarily on a certain era of mystery
definitely way back in blink and then
even in time of the angels um that one
you know had the whole idea of the image
of an angel as an angel and heck even in
angels in manhattan it's like what are
they doing and there's a little bit of
that here but for the most part this
isn't trying to build up the mystery of
the angels anymore and thankfully
doesn't try and
add new stuff to them that doesn't make
sense
statue of liberty
but
um it does instead try and focus on just
okay you know how the angels work let's
just try and execute that well
and again strictly from the visual the
movement the being sure that like when
lights are flickering in the brief
moment that it goes dead they jump
forward like
it's it's well done it's not new anymore
it's not fresh anymore but it's not
badly done it's competently handled
and if i'm gonna be honest the idea of a
rogue
angel
is kind of an interesting idea in and of
itself in the first place and the idea
that it actually took up residence
inside this woman's head
because she has premonitions and she had
a premonition of an angel and because in
her mind not even in her eye in her mind
she saw it it's now there
that's an interesting idea
so
as i said there's actually some
potential in some of the notions that
are here
it's squandered potential
because
ultimately
this all amounts to almost nothing
it
all it seems to do from a practical
standpoint is
split the doctor from
yaz and dan
other than that
what's going on isn't resolved really as
a story in and of itself one assumes
that it has to get picked up at least
somewhat next time because
like you have a planet just kind of
hanging out in this weird negative zone
kind of situation that's got to be
addressed so maybe i should be treating
this more like the first half of a
two-parter
except that doesn't feel right because
again within this own
series where the suntarens managed to be
a complete story that it was telling
there while also tying into the other
stuff
but
even within the story it's telling it's
very unsatisfying at least as we have so
far and yes i know some people will say
it's not over you should
give it a chance like look
if when the last episode airs it makes
me look back on all this stuff and go
wow actually i was wrong then you know
what when that episode airs i will say
that
but right now i'm going to talk about my
experience right now and not make a
prediction about how that will change
depending on the ending
all right
so
first of all
claire
does not appear at present to factor
into the overall story
and the way that they've chosen to tie
her in is weird and extraneous so
basically as part of her random
premonitions that she apparently has uh
she at some point had a vision of the
doctor and and of angels and of other
stuff and that prompted her in the first
episode to just approach this woman she
doesn't know and be like oh yeah and
like act like you like she knew what was
going on when she kind of didn't it's
like made clear that it's like vague
things and she doesn't really know
what's going on so like
now her performance in the first episode
makes no sense so
that now is a very unsatisfying answer
to who the heck was that woman like
she's a random woman who gets visions
okay
so
so what
the the rogue angel while i said it was
an interesting idea ultimately does it
matter to this story that it was a rogue
angel no
maybe it'll matter next episode but
again
i'm not going to presume that it will
and if it does and it changes my opinion
i'll say but within here right now the
whole idea of the rogue angel has no
immediate impact
it simply allows the doctor to
communicate with this person and like
honestly they could have redone the
angel bob bit and had the doctor
communicate with the angels in some
other way and i will say this i am glad
that
um chibnall remembered that the angels
are
cruel because i i got very nervous when
we had this whole idea of the rogue
angel and part of me was like when we
realized the town itself was like
floating in the like the quantum
whatever they said it was i can't even
remember now
but that whole thing i had a terrifying
thought i'm like
is he gonna have it be like the angels
are actually good guys and they're like
saving this town from the flux or
whatever
and no he doesn't go there they are on
somebody else's agenda i'll come back to
that but
uh he doesn't go there he remembers to
not only have them behave but remembers
to point out that they are cruel
they enjoy
messing with people
they are hunters by necessity but also
they like it so
you know thank you for remembering that
um the idea of the young girl seeing her
future self was not a terrible one and
it wasn't even that badly executed um
again
it didn't really mean anything because
this character either as the young
girl or the old woman
hasn't done anything
of note really she's just kind of there
as flavor and if this didn't have to
juggle
all of the overall series stuff maybe
there would have been time to flesh her
out and have her feel more like a proper
character and have her place in the
story
feel more necessary but
there isn't space for that
i did kind of like the professor
or i like the i like the performance of
the professor the writing of the
professor is very actually a lot of the
writing is
super super clunky especially for the
doctor
like there was a moment that i feel like
i could have clipped out
and zeroed in as to why i have a hard
time connecting with jody whittaker's
doctor
and that is when she is talking to the
angel inside claire's head
and it says how it got here and i forget
what it said it was technobabble um
and the doctor's question is how did you
do that
and even watching it live i'm sitting
there going
who cares how the question is why
why are you asking how she does
eventually ask why but i'm like
the in my mind the doctor's first
question is why
the doctor will only ask how
if the if there is no if either the
doctor already knows the answer to why
or knows that no answer is forthcoming
on that
you don't ask how first yes why first
and that just felt
off to me and again this is not me
saying and therefore she's not the
doctor
removed from canon retcon i mean no i'm
talking about why i'm having a hard time
connecting with her and that's that's
one more thing to factor in
i guess
so
i mentioned the clunky writing
and
like the professor has some very on the
nose lines there's a lot of on the nose
lines
uh for a lot of characters the doctor
doesn't get to be a character very much
the doctor is largely just here to shout
at other characters to not blink
and to figure out what's going on
i don't
i don't get much of a sense of
how she feels about anything
that's going on she's just kind of
mad dashing
and like
i'm not saying the doctor can't be a
little bit unscrutable they can they
have been i've liked them that way
sometimes
but you know i i could look at
the lines said by and the way that they
were said from someone like
tennant eccleston smith capaldi
tom baker
sylvester mccoy
and i could tell you
at least a general idea of how the
doctor is feeling about what's going on
and
with whitaker these lines are so
there's so much narrative clockwork
they're there to explain
what's going on to the audience and to
explain to the characters who wouldn't
have a reason to know how this works
but there's very little flavor in them
and
i'm sure some people will say she's been
written that way the whole time and i'm
not necessarily going to dispute that
but i don't remember it weighing on
the episode the way it weighed on it
here
again at least for me
so
there's that
can i just say how
i
i don't even know how to say this
so
when
the two people who i guess were the
guardians like great uncles or great
uncle or not something the the the
relatives and the guardians of the young
girl
they show up back in 1901 which actually
once i once uh the two of them showed up
there and 1901 have been dropped earlier
at the time and i really oh so they're
connecting oh that was one of the brief
moments of ooh
um that didn't go anywhere but like look
it had its moments
they show up again they get told you
know don't step in front of the angel
the angel touches them and this time
they die because for some reason this
little girl says nobody survives being
touched twice
how she knows that i don't know
but um regardless they both die
and this young girl has a line
it was something along the lines of he
was never nice to me
and i'm sitting there thinking okay but
what about her
his wife just died
she seemed like a nicer person she
seemed fed up with him
one why did she have to die in the first
place and two why is there no
acknowledgement of that
why are we just gonna focus on this guy
written deliberately to be a jerk and
have a little kiko i'm glad he's dead
okay but somebody else just died too why
is she not acknowledging this why is the
episode not acknowledging this what
like these characters don't care it
shouldn't be bothering me but it really
is
i can even get around the fact that the
little girl isn't acknowledging but it
feels like the episode has no
acknowledgement no character has an
acknowledgment of the fact that she died
too
it
it just
again it feels
narratively mechanical
there is no use for these characters at
this point so we get rid of both of them
we get rid of them in one fell swoop and
that guy was a jerk so we'll point that
out well yeah but you just use that as a
way to get rid
of this other person
and like you've now done that function
but you're not properly acknowledging
what the heck's going on
i know that's a very minor point to get
hung up on but it
it's the kind of thing that just it just
irked me all the way through i started
down on this tangent by pointing out
that i kind of like the professor i like
the performance given by the actor and
he did a very good job at managing to
portray a certain amount of uh
excitement stokeness you got a sense of
damage from him when he you know made
moments of standing his ground but also
you know you know you can tell it's this
wonderful mix of he's scared he's trying
to be brave he does have that stubborn
streak but there's he's also been
through a lot and this is kind of this
scenario is dredging some of that back
up for him
i thought the performance was very good
i thought the writing was
on him but i thought the performance was
very good the stuff
with
belle and vendor
it just kind of plugs along until we
know what
azul and swarm
want all those people in
passenger for it kind of has no meaning
because it gives us no new information
we knew that's how passenger was used
already
i think the only practical thing it
showed was that it actually showed the
damage that the previous episode only
talked about to the universe as a whole
so like there was a line from that guy
on the planet he's like we've got
you know
two-thirds of a sun a quarter of a moon
and half a planet it's the best we've
got so like moments like that and
actually seeing the visuals of it that
did kind of serve a function a little
bit but other than that there isn't for
how much screen time that
section got i don't
i don't know what we gained from that
and yes i know again some people say
wait till the end like
i just
it's a mess
and can we okay so let's let's circle
back on the fact that
the weeping angels
are working for
the division
the division has now become
possibly
at least one of the top three worst
offenders for a season arc
premise
which is that it's just they just slap
the name on whatever is going on
to make it seem relevant
i'll be able to tell you at the end of
this whether or not it's actually worse
than the hybrid which is my current
absolute worst series arc or mystery or
whatever that doctor who has done
um
but
it it it's it's giving it a run for its
money right now
because it keeps being brought up as if
it's something we're supposed to be
afraid of but we don't know what it does
not really we don't know why we don't
know to what end
so
as much as
the show can act like oh we know the
division is scary
we really only have this thing's word
for that
it's
and it the scope of it just keeps
expanding
because initially as introduced back
with fugitive of the jedoon
this was something that seemed to be a
time lord thing
and now it's something that recruits
anybody and everybody
and knows everything and controls
everything and and now i don't care i
barely care before i really don't care
now
these kind of overwritten overpowerful
ooh they are pulling all the strings and
controlling i never buy it
whether it's a single person or an
organization i never ever buy it nobody
has that much control and if they do
that is a boring scenario
i have no interest in that
unless you're gonna tie it to a real
world situation
it's a bit like you know what it's a bit
like whenever the stakes get so big like
oh the whole universe is gonna explode
i'm like well now like i'm taken out of
it because you made it too big i
actually kind of detach from it i can't
relate to that
when you take this villainous
organization that is so huge and massive
it can even recruit something like the
weeping angels to work for it
i don't buy it and i don't care
it's like
it's like spectre when they tried to
tell us that not only was blofeld james
bond's secret brother but
uh that he had been the secret
mastermind behind the completely
disparate plots of the previous three
movies and it's like no
no
you're trying to make this being a
threatening and i just don't buy it at
all
and that's kind of where i'm at with the
division at this point too
so whatever enjoyment i might have had
out of the more isolated scenario of the
angels in this situation and some of the
neat ideas involved in that by tying
them so directly to the division and
giving us just a
painful cliffhanger
i mean i've said that almost every time
i don't like doctor who cliffhangers if
you do great i don't in general even
when they're in stories i like i usually
don't like doctor who cliffhangers
but
i just
by the time this was done
i had to really stop and think about why
i had ever thought that maybe it was
going to be good this time
and i did think of that and i mentioned
some of the stuff some of the executions
with the angels some of the core ideas
some of the performances
it's not completely devoid of quality
it's just all put in service of a story
that
doesn't seem to be going
to a destination so much as accumulating
more stuff as it rolls down the hill and
eventually it's just gonna smash into
something at the bottom and make a big
mess
i would like to be proven wrong
i know there are some people who say i
went into this wanting to hate it i
don't want to i never want to hate
doctor who i want to love doctor who and
i would like nothing more than for the
last episode of this to come out and for
me to go i was wrong it all makes sense
it all ties together it was all done the
way it should have been i would love
nothing more than to have that happen
but i'm not gonna hold my breath
expecting it
village of the angels
what did you think about it
it sort of left me more bummed out than
actively angry personally
because it kind of
it leaves me a position where i'm left
feeling that war of the suntarens was
probably just a fluke something that i
liked
and i should just accept that that's
going to be it
we'll see
again i want to be wrong
i really do
whatever your thoughts are on this drop
them down in the comments let's talk
about it
usual stuff all the likes subscribes and
etc etc they do help me out but
i won't put too much pressure on you for
that
because at the end of the day
you are the council
i just run the meetings
and until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey if you're sticking around through
the credits might as well hear some
names read out my patreon helps support
this and in particular i want to thank
raven mcbain bookworm mj tracy scrabbit
vincent paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz
edelen robin moore ross schultz shayla
gourlay wanna hear me mispronounce your
name check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]